الفنان محمد فؤاد من امس متصدر الترند
والمنصات من بعد ما كان ضيف برنامج
المقالب لرامز جلال اللي بيعرض في هذا
الموسم رامز سببه مول مقلب وانما صحه محمد
فؤاد اللي اقلقت كثار من بعد المقلب لانه
كان قال في بدايه الحلقه انه هو عمل عمليه
تكميم معده من 15 يوم المقلب كان داخل
غرفه الغساله اللي بس دخلها محمد فؤاد
بدات دوران والخط قضى وكانه داخل غساله
رسميه المقلب انتهى بمحمد فؤاد على الارض
وهو بيتفقد الجرح اللي يبدو انه انتهى
بنزيف كمان
الناس من بعد المقلب تداولت مقاطع مقلب
وصور منه كثار ومنهم محبين الفنان وصفحات
فانزلو وهاجمت رامز باشد العبارات
واعتبروا اللي صار غير انساني ومن بينهم
الغاضبين ومن بين الغاضبين والمهاجمين كان
في طبيب محمد فؤاد الدكتور اسامه طه اللي
نشر بوست على صفحته على فيسبوك ووصف اللي
صار بالخطير وجريمه شنعاء من الممكن انه
يخسر محمد فؤاد حياته لانه العمليه اللي
عاملها عمليه تصحيح لعمليه قبلها من عشر
سنوات وبتتطلب حذر في التعامل مع الجرح
وقال نصا كيف تدنى الاخلاص لمستوى اللام
مسؤوليه في عفوا كيف تدنى الاخلاق لمستوى
المسؤوليه في سبيل اسعاد جمهور ليس سعيدا
بما حدث وقال انه بيحمل البرنامج كامل
المسؤوليه في حال صار اي شيء ولكن الناس
تفاجات ان البوست ما عاد موجوده على
الصفحه ووضح الدكتور السبب في تصريح
اعلامي انه حول البو للاصدقاء فقط لانه
طبيب وما بيحب الدوشه وشاف الناس بتتكلم
عن محمد فؤاد بطريقه مو لائقه وانه محمد
فؤاد اتصل فيه وقال له انه هو بخير وصحه
جيده
[موسيقى]